[Musique]
cherche colocataires comme on va vivre
ensemble pour la bonne entente de la
coloc avec ma cousine charlet on a
décidé que ce soir on allait faire un
jeu qu'est-ce qui courent et qui se
jettent une courgette quel plat sans le
cul des vaches
eh bien c'est la langue de boeuf pour
ceux qui ne le savaient pas qu'est ce
qu'un lampadaire une lampe avec une
bosse comment appelle-t-on les parents
de l'homme invisible les transparents
melon ils me laissent vient d'ouvrir une
boulangerie me l'ont fait les baguettes
et me lâchent les miches salaces et un
rire du chêne un authentique rire du
chêne alors donnez ce que tu veux contre
explique des règles de fonds propres
jeux
[Rires]
[Musique]
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
on a plusieurs façons de rire comme les
scientifiques adore ranger les choses
c'est leur côté marie condos ils ont
rangé ses rires en plusieurs catégories
d'abord le rire authentique et spontané
comme moi qu'on appelle le rire du chêne
et ensuite tout le reste bien merci les
mecs non en vrai c'est parce que les
deux types de rire n'emprunte pas les
mêmes circuits dans le cerveau parmi les
rires jugé non authentique il ya le rire
conversationnel qui ponctuent nos fins
de phrases le rire gêné suit vous avez
quand j'essaye des drôles la genre
maintenant le rire poli le rire nerveux
le lien moqueur bref tout ça ce qu'on
appelle leur nom du chêne du médecin
français guillaume duchenne de boulogne
un très grand clinicien du 19ème et
fondateur de la neurologie
son truc à lui c'est est de s'amuser
avec l'électricité pour voir comment les
muscles du corps humains réagissent
c'est comme ça qu'il a décrit diverses
expressions faciales en électrifiant
notamment le visage d'un patient
paralysé dans le lot il y avait bien
évidemment le sourire et le rire vrai et
voilà donc comment se manifeste ce
fameux rire du chêne montée tu serais
dix mois pour un truc là c'est pour la
science j'espère que ça vaut le coup ce
que j'ai un truc à faire là donc va dire
le rire du chêne l'authentic nécessite
l'action conjuguée de -15 muscles
faciaux notamment les zygomatiques
les points de la bouche recul et remonte
on contracte aussi les muscles des yeux
les orbicularis oculi en conséquence les
pommettes route et les yeux se plissent
et c'est précisément grâce à ses muscles
des yeux qu'on arrive à distinguer le
vrai rire du rire forcé est le vrai du
faux sourire mais elle fait un effort
mais je fais un effort je suis heureux
ça se voit pas valentine
vient ensuite le rire à proprement
parler c'est une expiration soudaine
suivi de cycle d'inspiration expiration
saccadé contrairement à la respiration
normale
on expulse eu l'air de ses poumons de
manière active en contractant ses abdos
en sollicitant son diaphragme et sa cage
thoracique
c'est du sport pendant l'expiration on
peut émettre des interjections primaires
comme aaa aux fichiers typiquement
quatre à la suite avec une intensité des
croissante au fur et à mesure qu on
expire parce qu'on a de moins en moins
d'air dans les poumons shakara dure à
peu près 75 ml secondes et il est séparé
deux suivants par un silence de 210000
secondes c'est très précises
la science
le rire peut être extrêmement différent
d'une personne à une autre même si en
moyenne le rire d'une femme aura une
fréquence fondamentale de 500 de hertz
comme ceux ci est celui d'un homme est
plutôt aux alentours de 260 16
hertz et en général on à rire plus aigus
quand on se fait chatouiller
mais malgré ces variations dans la forme
le rire est universel chez l'humain
l'historien alain vaillant par le même
d'une itt et anthropologique essentiel
c'est un invariant à travers toutes les
cultures au même titre que les
structures de parenté et la religion le
langage ou l'attrait pour le beurre salé
ah non ça c'est uniquement les bretons
on trouve même des clowns tribaux c'est
des personnages burlesques le plus
souvent des hommes qui transgressent les
règles pour amuser la galerie limite les
danseurs en dansant comme un pied à
contretemps il interrompt bruyamment les
incantations religieuses en parlant à
tort et à travers
en gros ils font des pitreries qui font
mourir de rire tout le monde souvent on
leur attribue même des pouvoirs de
guérison un peu comme les chamans se
rivent qui est universel chez l'humain
donc à quoi il peut bien nous servir
déjà il faut savoir que c'est une forme
de communication qui apparaît bien avant
la parole
on aimait notre première éclat de rire
quand on a entre 4 et 6 mois et qu'on
réalise enfin l'absurdité de la vie
qu'on apprend qu'on va devoir trimer
comme des bêtes pour ne pas toucher de
retraite et que de toute façon on va
mourir seul
ou alors juste quand on se fait
chatouiller ou qu'on joue à des jeux
comme coucou qui sait des chercheurs se
sont aperçus que des enfants né sourd et
aveugle arrive à rire spontanément sans
même avoir pu l'apprendre de leur
entourage
et ça ça laisse à penser que le rire
sera un réflexe c'est à dire une réponse
involontaire très rapide et stéréotypé
un stimulus un réflexe donc inné chez
l'homme et pas que chez l'homme
d'ailleurs certains animaux se bidonne
aussi regarder
ce bon vieux darwin s'était déjà penché
sur nos cousins poilus je parle pas de
ma cousine charlet c'est dégoûtant
darwin donc qui décrivait le rire comme
l'expression primitif de la joie à
identifier un comportement similaire
chez les singes macaques babouins
chimpanzés bonobos orangs outans gorille
tous affichent une expression
caractéristiques quand il joue où quand
et se chatouillent c'est la ''place un
visage détendu bouche ouverte couvrant
leurs dents avec leurs lèvres certains
comme les chimpanzés et met aussi des
vocalisations qui ressemble à notre rire
une sorte de allaitement
vous aurez remarqué que contrairement à
nous ils émettent un son en inspirant et
en expirant un peu comme ça alors que
nous c'est plutôt ça mais alors pourquoi
le nôtre est il si différent de celui
des autres primates
apparemment il s'est passé un truc
quelque part après que notre branche et
divergeaient de celles des chimpanzés
bonobos il ya environ six millions
d'années avant ma mère mais quel truc et
bah on s'est peut-être qu'il ya rien eu
du tout notre réseau juste c'était pimpé
par hasard est conservé au cours de
l'évolution c'est fort probable mais
pour certains chercheurs l'apparition de
notre rire si particulier aurait pu être
favorisée par la bipédie vous savez ce
moment on s'est dit que ça coûterait
moins cher en chaussures de marcher sur
deux pattes et ne tiendrait mieux dans
le métro comme ça c'est là bas et pilot
série pour la comprendre il faut d'abord
s'intéresser à la version 4 pattes pour
la comparer à la version 2 bat c'est une
histoire de biomécanique
les chercheurs se sont rendu compte que
les mammifères quadrupèdes ont une
respiration calés sur leurs démarches
ce pattern serait directement liée au
fait qu'ils se déplacent à quatre pattes
comme le thorax et comprimé à chaque
fois qu'ils posent le pied par terre
eh ben ils ne peuvent respirer qu'entre
chaque pas ça les contraindraient donc à
calais une respiration par enjambées
grâce à la bipédie l'humain se serait
affranchi de ses contraintes de
compression du thorax
ce qui nous aurait permis d'allonger
considérablement dans respiration et ça
nous aurait permis de développer par la
même occasion des petites fantaisies
comme le rire est plus tard le langage
ce qui me permet aujourd'hui de vous
raconter tout ça nature est bien faite
en 2009 des chercheurs américains et
allemands sont même allés plus loin ils
ont tenté de deviner comment riels
ancêtre commun à tous les primates
pour ça ils ont chatouillé des bébés
humains ainsi que 21 bébé orang outan
gorille
j'ai repensé et bonobo être adorable
puis ils ont accroché ses différents
enregistrements de rigolade sur les
branches de l'arbre du vivant
ils ont arrosé le tout copieusement avec
d analyse phylogénétique et ils ont
déraciné l'arbre pour retrouver notre
ancêtre commun qui vivait il ya 10 à 16
millions d'années avant un justin bieber
et qui en définitive ce poêle est
probablement comme nos cousins poilus
encore une fois pas cher mais au final
le rire du papy de tous les primates
ressembler probablement à des courtes
séries de cris formé d'expiration
successives et très sale avec plein de
fréquences dedans comme ce qu'on a
entendu chez les chimpanzés donc déjà ce
qu'on peut dire à ce niveau de
l'histoire c'est que le rire n'est pas
du tout le propre de l'homme
non aux spécimens mais c'est pas fini si
vous croyez que les primates sont les
seuls à se poiler écouter un peu ça il y
a vingt ans le neuroscientifique
estonien iacp accepte s'est amusé à
chatouiller des rats de laboratoires
princeps et donc aperçu qu'un rat
chatouiller gas-oil aux alentours de 50
kg art dans les ultrasons des sons que
notre oreille n'entend pas et que le
scientifique a découvert grâce à un
appareil pour écouter les chauves-souris
à la base il a constaté les mêmes
pépiements ultrasonique quand les bébés
rats jouent entre eux ou quand les
adultes s'accouplent pour pang cep
s'écrit s'apparente à un reer sa
conclusion a laissé perplexe une bonne
partie de la communauté scientifique
mais lui il en est convaincu ce
pépiements ultrasonique est associé à
une émotion positive et les rats sont
plus optimistes et de meilleure humeur
après avoir gazouiller et oui il ya des
expériences pour mesurer l'optimisme
noir depuis des chercheurs milite même
pour qu'on chante aussi les rats de
laboratoire pour augmenter leur
bien-être
on leur doit bien ça après tout mais les
rats ne sont pas les seuls mammifères
sociaux à se payer une tranche de
rigolade
des études ont conclu positivement pour
le grand dauphin vous savez notre pote
flipper et pour le chien alors pour le
dauphin il s'agirait d'une série de
pulsations brève suivi d'un sifflement
qu'ils émettent quand ils se chamaillent
les chercheurs pensent qu'ils
émettraient ce sont pour signaler à
leurs camarades qui font que jouer à la
bagarre que c'est pour de faux
et c'est justement une des hypothèses
évolutif sur le rôle du rire d'après
cette théorie la fonction primaire du
rire aurait été de dire à ses petits
copains
vous avez entendu ce bruit là non c'est
bon j'ai vérifié ya pas de danger pour
d'autres chercheurs le rire sera un
moyen de répondre rapidement la bonne
humeur autour de soi c'est ce qu'on
appelle la théorie de la contagion
émotionnelle ce qui permettrait de bien
disposés son interlocuteur pour qu'ils
coopèrent avec nous c'est d'ailleurs une
des fonctions évolutif qu'on donne à
l'humour tu fais rigoler les gens autour
de toi dans l'espoir qu'ils viennent
aider dans le futur quand on aura besoin
d'un coup de main
[Musique]
du coup le rire c'est forcément utilisés
dans un pub ah oui oui mais le rire
c'est l'émotion qui fait le plus vendre
en fait on va tu as une pub ça sert à
quoi ça sert il ya plusieurs objectifs
il faut capter l'attention
il faut convaincre la personne qui la
voix évolue qu'il mémorise aussi la
marque et ce genre de choses et le rire
savoure ça peut vraiment servir en fait
à toutes ces parties là dans tous les
cas l'affect va toujours plus marquée
que l'intellect pour ça d'ailleurs que
ben t'as beaucoup plus publicité qui
vont jouer sur le fait de générer des
émotions que de commencer injuste lister
ce produit sert à ça ça ça juste des
arguments de vente de manière hyper
austère quoi ça c'est un sas un premier
point après jouer sur l'émotion oui si
tu peux jouer sur pleins d'émotions mais
tout ce qui est motion négative
forcément ses associés des notions
négative à une marque est toujours un
peu risqué
quelque chose que les gens du marketing
aime pas trop donc on préfère les sur
des trucs assez sef donc finalement pas
faire de l'humour faire du rire ce que
ben 2 1
tu as un côté pas tout le monde aime
rire ça détend ça capte comme ça
naturellement sacré la sympathie et ça
va justement créé cette forme de
relation finalement avec le spectateur
qui tombe devant la publicité va
vraiment créer un rapport entre les deux
et par cette interaction finalement ils
baissent un peu sa garde toi il est géré
à la piscine fait marrer donc j'ai
beaucoup moins attentifs à tous les plus
rationnels après le rire ça marche pas
dans tous les cas parce que suivant vote
différents produits t'as pas le même
niveau d'application tu as achète une
voiture où tu achètes un soda c'est pas
vraiment le même niveau d un choix
beaucoup plus réfléchir et de poser le
camp gros plus le produit demande de
l'investissement de la réflexion et de
rationaliser le truc plus maîtres du
rire dans la communication et est risqué
même si on vrai ça se fait mais c'est
juste c'est plus risqué ça doit se faire
de manière beaucoup plus dosée fait
rigoler pour vendre du soda mais pas une
voiture alors tu peux tu peux autant ne
pas fait rigoler point du soleil tu peux
faire rigoler pouvoir une voiture c'est
juste que c'est plus dangereuse plus
risqués vous faire attention il faut
voir aussi comment le faire c'est très
dur de faire des publicités
humoristiques dans le cadre de trucs
sérieux type assurance genre de choses
après il ya une expérience qu'elle était
faite où justement on a testé qu'en fait
plus suivant le type d'humour la cible
est le produit c'est plein de facteurs
qui font que ça influence vraiment
l'efficacité d'une publicité
on a remarqué par exemple que l'humour
absurde c'était mieux pour la persuasion
q
l'humour sexuelle un peu beau ça
marchait mieux pour la mémorisation
mais à linverse ce qu'ils pouvaient tuer
la mémorisation c'était de l'humour un
peu provocant par exemple voilà donc on
peut dire en gros qui effectivement le
rire c'est très utilisé en publicité
parce que c'est démontrer que ça a
vraiment des vrais effets sur le cerveau
en termes de mémorisation mais même de
sympathie envers la marque d'engagement
envers une marque m6 simplement pour
capter l'attention puisque sur ou un
truc dynamique qui se passera beaucoup
plus accrochée parce que on a intrigué
au début qu'on voit qu'il va avoir une
chute qui va voir un truc marrant plutôt
que effectivement comme je l'aï dit tout
à l'heure de lister les arguments ce
qu'il vient de dire ça me fait penser à
l'aspect contagieux du rire verde
difficile de rester de marbre quand on
entend des rires c'est un truc que les
producteurs de sitcom bien compris un
peu trop bien compris même tiens ça fait
penser genre en tanzanie dans les années
soixante à peu près il y avait une école
qui avait pris un fou rire mais genre un
truc de malade ce qu'il y avait des
gamins qui avaient transmis leurs
propres fous rires à leurs parents
qu'ils les ont transmis aux villages
alentours ce qui fait qu'à la fin il y
avait près 1000 personnes qui avaient un
fou rire incontrôlable et sa durée genre
un an et demi mais c'est horrible c'est
souvent banon c'est super drôle je
trouve mais ça un cas d'hystérie
collective au château bah je sais pas en
tout cas moi je voulais connaître la bac
de base
oui on sait maintenant les scientifiques
soupçonnent que le rire fonctionnerait
un peu comme le bâillement finalement
par un réseau de neurones miroirs mais
surtout la caractéristique principale du
rire c'est qu'il est social le
philosophe henri bergson avait déjà
souligné cette dimension en 1900 il
écrivait que le rire a besoin d'un éco
écouter le bien ce n'est pas un sont
articulés net terminée c'est quelque
chose qui voudraient se prolonger en se
répercutant de proche en proche
quelque chose qui commence par un éclat
pour se continuer par des roulements
ainsi que le tonnerre dans la montagne
vachement émouvant est tellement juste
bon ok il a aussi écrit dans le même
livre qu'on rie est des [ __ ] parce que
notre imagination les voyait comme des
blancs mal lavés au visage barbouillé
d'encre ou de suie coup dur pour
personne même si bon l'époque le
contexte tout ça même donc le rire et
social en réalité on a trente fois plus
de chances de s'esclaffer canton avec
des gens plutôt que quand on est tout
seul
et là je vous vois venir mais peu
tu dis n'importe quoi je rigole tout le
temps tout seul ce à quoi je vous
répondrais vous êtes sûr vous étiez pas
ce moment là en train de jeu pad
repenser une conversation que vous
auriez eu plutôt en train de lire un
livre vous de regarder une vidéo
hilarante comme celle ci donc que vous
étiez pas vraiment seul au final et si
vous me dites que non vraiment là je
vous dirais un autant pour moi 2 que
c'est un peu triste quelque part de rire
tout seul que trois ça m'arrive souvent
aussi et du coup que 4 je confirme que
c'est un peu triste et surtout 5 j'ai
pas vraiment d'explication scientifique
mais j'en ai une quand même parce que
j'ai réponse à tout et c'est ce
débonnaire de charles baudelaire qui
nous la donne en fait d'après lui quand
on s'esclaffe tout seul on rit de se
voir rire c'est parce qu'en fait on se
dédouble et une part de nous se réjouit
du rire de l'autre parent à méditer
bref cet aspect social du rire est aussi
valable chez les autres primates parce
que les singes aussi s'esclaffe
principalement quand ils sont avec leurs
compères est rarement tout seul
les chercheurs pensent que le rire est
avec lui l'humour serait un lubrifiant
social
rigolez pas c'est très simple en gros il
servira à consolider les liens sociaux
et affectifs
certains d'entre eux considère même le
rire et l'humour comme une caresse par
procuration puisqu'une bonne marrade
procurait le même plaisir qu'un contact
physique précise pas quel type de
contact mais ce qui est marrant c'est
que la plupart du temps le rire n'est
pas du tout associé à l'humour en l'an
2000 alors qu'on élise est la première
femme présidente de finlande que la
station spatiale internationale
accueillait ses tout premiers occupants
et que la reine d'angleterre souffler
ses 210 bouger le chercheur américain
robert provine lui écoutait les
conversations des gens dans la rue ils
analysent au total 1200 épisode de
grosses rigolades
résultat moins d'un rire sur cinq
répondait à un trait d'humour la plupart
du temps c'était plutôt pour ponctuer
des répliques banal comme regarde c'est
jean michel tu es sûr où c'était
chouette de te rencontrer ce sera avant
tout pour créer du lien avec son
interlocuteur du coup le mot en
particulier fait appel au rire du chêne
le vrai l'authentiqué toujours imité
jamais égalé
mais dans une conversation 8 à n'offrir
sur dix seraient des rires fake
ce serait des rires non du chêne on
pense que ce rire là sera paru plus tard
au cours de l'évolution par détournement
du rire vrai ce qui nous amène justement
au côté obscur du rire
ce qui me permet d'écouler à nouveau du
personnel histoire de rentabiliser le
temps que j'ai passé à se coller des
images de citations inspirante
le rire dit-il peut cheminer à
l'intérieur d'un cercle aussi large
qu'on voudra le cercle n'en reste pas
moins fermé notre rire et toujours le
rire d'un groupe un homme à qui l'on
demandait pourquoi il ne pleurait pas un
sermon tout le monde verser des larmes
répondit je ne suis pas de la paroisse
ce que cet homme pensait des larmes
serait bien plus vrai du rire et c'est
là qu'est tout le drame le rapproche
mais s'il exclut aussi là on parle
toujours uniquement du rire non du chêne
le rire non spontané ce qu'on appelle le
côté noir du rire donc est liée
notamment à la théorie de la supériorité
défendu par quelques philosophes comme
aristote platon obs et devinez je vous
le donne en mille
exactement oui c'est lui berck sonne il
disait d'ailleurs le rire à pau
fonctionner la mort il y en a marre on
n'en peut plus de personnes là c'est
fini
ok mais le soul mais il parle bien donc
selon cette théorie rigoler permettrait
de se sentir supérieur à son
interlocuteur c'est typiquement ce qui
se passe quand on se moque de quelqu'un
en fait on le rabaisse on tourne en
ridicule c'est la différence entre rire
avec et rire de quelqu'un c'est aussi le
rire qu'on utilise pour ponctuer une
phrase blessante et faire passer la
pilule alors qu'en fait on rigole pas du
tout vous voyez très bien ce à quoi je
fais allusion
personne n'est dupe âgées une citation
pour ça si c'est pas besoin de ce coup
là c'est offs
la passion du real n'est rien d'autre
qu'une gloire soudaine et dans ce
sentiment de gloire il est toujours
question de se glorifier par rapport à
autrui
de sorte que lorsqu'on ray de vous on se
moque de vous on triomphe de vous et on
vous méprise il n'aimait pas trop
rigoler et sans aller jusqu'à la
moquerie le simple fait de pas
comprendre une blague et ça peut
engendrer un sentiment d'exclusion c'est
d'ailleurs la fonction ultime du rire et
de l'humour telle que proposée par
riesch à alexander en 1986 pour lui
l'humour s'est développée initialement
en tant qu'outil sociale qui facilite
l'exclusion et la formation de
coalitions ceux qui rient ensemble se
rapproche et ostracisme les autres c'est
mal d'ostraciser août rue c'est en tout
cas un moyen de manipuler son statut
social en s'élevant soi même et ses
complices et en rabaissant les autres ça
c'est la théorie de la manipulation
sociale
il ya aussi le cas très particulier de
l'auto dérision quand on se moque de soi
même on se rabaisse du coup c'est un peu
contre intuitif pourquoi on fait ça
d'après alexander il ya des points
positifs à cette affaire
à permettre à la fois d'élever le statut
de l'auditeur pour améliorer notre
relation avec lui de montrer qu'on est
tellement haut dans la hiérarchie
sociale que de toute façon on peut se
permettre de blaguer sur nous on craint
rien et puis il ya aussi ce que j'ai
baptisé à l'instant même les faits même
pas mal si quelqu'un se moquent de nous
et qu'on rigole avec lui on désamorce eu
l'effet de la blague montre
ostensiblement qu'elle nous porte pas
préjudice même pas mal inversement quand
on fait exprès de ne pas rire à la
blague de quelqu'un ça permet de
rabaisser le statut de cette personne
est de montrer que nous on vaut mieux
que ça et c'est là tout le pouvoir du
rire non du chêne après cette théorie de
la manipulation sociale a ses limites
principalement son auteur s'est
focalisée sur les blagues comportant un
souffre douleur alors que le mob assez
loin de se résumer à ça mais bon ça
donne toujours des pistes de réflexion
récapitulons une épidémie de fous rires
à paralyser un bout de la tanzanie
pendant un an et demi l'ancêtre commun
des primates rigoler comme un
asthmatique berkman a dit plein de
choses et tout le monde sont fois par
mois les rats gazouille quand ils sont
heureux on rigole rarement parce que
c'est drôle mais surtout pour créer du
lien et caresser virtuellement nos
proches mais on peut aussi s'en servir
pour abaisser les gens en tout cas
aujourd'hui on sait pas vraiment
définitivement pour sûr pourquoi on
rigole on se dit que c'est un signal de
communication bien antérieure à la
parole mais pour dire quoi
étrangement c'est un sujet assez peu
étudié peut-être parce qu'il n'a pas
l'air assez sérieux et c'est vraiment
dommage parce que c'est un sujet qui ne
touche absolument tous enfin sauf honte
et et comme disait bergson table des
matières je vous l'accordé c'est pas sa
meilleure
merci abonne toi mais la cloche et si tu
aimes les caresses par procuration like
cette vidéo n'hésite pas à la partager
pour toujours plus de machines des
bretons et retrouvez nous sur le
discorde pour discuter du beurre demi
sel
du coup j'ai pas compris si j'ai perdu
ou pas moi j'ai carrément pas compris le
but du jeu je raison que le goal du
trouvé que c'était un peu de côté le
malaise arrière à boncourt j'ai
l'impression qu'on a plutôt créé le
malaise en fait abba a littéralement
atteint comme en salle est derrière toi
le show relève le cousine de ballantyne
dacquois a tellement ri qu'elle a fait
un malaise
ah merde c'est pas grave j'espère moi je
sais pas réveiller là pour voir tu
verras bien non et non d'un problème ça
vous a plu
vous en voulez encore alors rejoignez
moi maintenant tout de suite sur twitch
où je suis pendant que cette vidéo est
mise en ligne
et comme ça on va pouvoir débriefer tous
ensemble et j'ai même des contenus
exclusifs à montrer des petits trucs que
j'ai glané au fil de mes recherches et
et venez ça va être ludique